[Music]
thank you very much for joining us i'm
john langler and we start with new
polling from the aarp it shows nevada's
senate and gubernatorial races are still
very tight in the senate race incumbent
democrat catherine cortez masto still
has a slight four-point lead over
republican adam laxalt about 16 percent
picked other options among hispanic
voters the senator holds a 46 to 32
percent lead and they were tied among
independents as you see here at 37
percent each in the governor's race
incumbent democrat steve sisselak leads
republican joe lombardo by three points
20 percent picked other options
the hispanic vote closer in the
governor's race governor sislek now as
you see there has a 10 point lead clark
county sheriff joe lombardo the
opposition has a two-point lead among
independents at 34 to 32 percent
meanwhile this week president joe biden
took aim at his predecessor former
president donald trump in a speech on
thursday mr biden called mr trump and
his allies threats to democracy the
president defined the upcoming midterms
as a battle for the soul of the nation
jesse chinor reports
donald trump and the migrant republicans
represented extremism president joe
biden gave a stark warning to voters
ahead of the november elections not only
in a key battleground state but in
philadelphia where the founders signed
the declaration of independence and
wrote the constitution equality and
democracy
are under assault the president blamed
donald trump and his allies for the
recent threats against police officers
poll workers and fbi agents while he
touted bipartisan wins in congress on
guns and infrastructure there are far
more americans
far more americans
from every from every background of
belief
who reject the extreme mag ideology
than those that accept it but more than
74 million americans voted for trump in
2020 and some of his biggest supporters
in congress flipped the script on
president biden joe biden has launched
an assault
on the soul of america house republican
leader kevin mccarthy argues the economy
immigration crime and education have
only worsened under democrats control of
the white house and congress millions of
americans are falling backwards into
poverty mccarthy hopes to be speaker
next year and promises if americans put
republicans in control of the house they
will pass legislation to give parents
more control over schools and
investigate government agencies like the
justice department we will restore the
soul of america
in washington i'm jessie tanor
back here in nevada other races are
starting to heat up democratic
congressman dina titus has launched this
her first ad in her re-election campaign
her opponent for district one is
republican mark robertson he hasn't
bought any tv time just yet in the
governor's race as you mentioned joe
lombardo the republican is running
attack ads against incumbent governor
steve sisilak it's over a scandal
involving covet 19 testing contracts the
company involved north shore billed 165
million dollars to the state for testing
96 of those tests later turned out to be
inaccurate mr lombardo has asked the
legislature to set aside money for those
north shore victims
meanwhile i spoke with las vegas review
journal politics and government editor
steve sebelius about the hispanic vote
leading into the midterms and we also
discussed whether by administration
officials campaigning here in nevada is
good or bad for democrats
one thing that you and i talked about a
while ago when president biden's
approval ratings were at pretty low
levels in the 30 range
was you were suggesting potentially that
you don't think that he may be coming to
las vegas very often ordered in nevada
to support the candidates things have
changed a little bit as an approval
rating nationwide has gone up slightly
do you envision that changing at all
that whether it's president biden or the
vice president more of that white house
leadership might come to nevada as we
get down towards uh election day i i
still think it's it's probably dubious
for that to happen uh
president biden's approval rating has
gone up and it's gone up because he's
accomplished quite a few things uh when
you uh when you you know look away from
the daily uh papers and just see a list
of the things you've done it's actually
quite impressive
but but i still think uh that he would
probably in the environment that we're
in now probably be more of a liability
to a candidate than a than an asset and
so i don't think uh you'll see that uh
uh before the end of the campaign um
with the president or the vice president
frankly vice president kamal harris has
been here a couple of times recently
talking about lake mead and so forth but
the president has been here in some time
uh final question here let's talk about
another issue that has lingered for a
long long time it's a very important
issue in nevada
latino voters it's such an important
part of our community and of the
electorate right now and both major
parties are pushing to try and get that
vote right now
what kind of outrage has been made
into the latino community into those
organizations to try and make that sway
republicans have really kind of upped
their game in this area because
they see an opportunity there
i don't know how big of an opportunity
it actually is but
president trump famously got more
hispanic voters in 2020 than he did in
2016 and so republicans i think are
looking at that as an opportunity and so
the campaigns have
have groups like latinos for laxalt
the lombardo campaign has a hispanic
outreach person
they're not neglecting that community
which is very smart because uh you you
can't take them for granted harry reid
uh the late harry reid once famously
said you know i don't understand why
anyone who is a latino would vote for a
republican and that i think kind of
betrayed this idea that that those votes
belong to a certain party and they
certainly don't and there are there are
ways that republicans can sort of reach
out to that community and i think
they're trying to do that in in many
different
ways voter registration numbers still
favor democrats here in nevada however
republicans keep closing ground two
years ago democrats had an 87 thousand
person registration advantage across
nevada as you can see on your screen
there republicans have nearly cut that
number in half it's about 46 thousand
now
next on politics now keeping criminals
out las vegas says it's the goal of a
new plan up next to challenges a
proposed new stay out order could face
running short on teachers new proposals
to try and turn around a nationwide
teacher
silver state schools credit union
welcome back to politics now
a republican running for clark county
administrator now faces a dui charge
happened after a metro police traffic
stop on that woman they are patsy brown
officers say they found an open bottle
of vodka and a red solo cup of alcohol
in her car at the time
brown is also in trouble for driving
without headlights brown's campaign sent
us the letter you see on your screen
there gives her version of events and
it's different than what you hear from
metro police we have the full story for
you at 8newsnow.com
vandalism at the reno office of
republican nevada gubernatorial
candidate joe lombardo this picture you
can see there shows a broken window
campaign staff it happened early
wednesday morning and that is at
mr lombardo's office in response nevada
party chair michael mcdonald tweeted
this
it's time to start hitting back
continuing do it at the ballot box let
your voice let your vote rather be your
voice
earlier this year clark county
instituted an order out ordinance it
allows the judge to ban people from the
las vegas strip for up to a year if they
have prior felony convictions so now the
city of las vegas is considering a
similar measure the proposal would
impact as you see there most of downtown
from washington down to sahara and i-15
to eastern it's a measure that concerns
the executive director of nevada's aclu
chapter atar hasiboula
the order out provisions and clark
county just passed one that's you know
we're we're assessing that we're looking
at that that might be subject to a
challenge at some point there's
complexities associated with the way
that things are drafted and they're
drafted in very clever fashions to try
to give maximum flexibility to those
that are drafting it to say you know
it's really at the court's discretion as
a condition of
of uh of an alternative really to
incarceration at that period when
there's
when that's occurring but really what
we're seeing right now by the city of
las vegas is an even more sweeping uh
attempt at creating an order out
provision and so this isn't even
downtown las vegas the last parameter we
checked was i guess it depends on how
you divide downtown but looks like it
extended to eastern what is most
concerning to you about the order out
corridors in the begin period before we
talk about the city of las vegas just
the general concept of having an order
out provision is problematic on a number
of fronts the the biggest of which is it
fundamentally interferes with basic
constitutional liberties so if you
define a corridor and you have a
corridor any specific area and the
provision from a court comes back and
says you know you cannot be in this area
particularly when it's just a an area
that's really driven by what they're you
know purporting to be tourism and
tourism and related issues and
potential income that that is derived
there versus any sort of real rational
basis or logical connection to what is
occurring there it becomes problematic
and so you have the ability
to really interfere with those rights
that might include first amendment
rights but it also includes the ability
of someone to even travel through and
pass through that area without even
having knowledge
that they might need to go through that
area so they're going to have to try to
find a way to work around a confined
area with no basis to really do so but
those who are behind this suggest that
order out quarters it's not for sort of
anyone these are people with criminal
backgrounds that they're trying to sort
of sort of keep out of
areas with a lot of people populated
areas so that there's a criminal element
to this versus just sort of saying you
can't go downtown or you can't go on the
strip well so when this was initially
utilized which you know we weren't
supportive of then because it still
interfered with rights but when it was
initially utilized it was primarily
utilized in situations as they defined
it with respect to prostitution-related
offenses
and those that emanated there from and
they were trying to prevent that from
being very pervasive in certain areas
like this what these provisions now have
done is expanded to any crime
so you can be accused of anything that
has nothing to do with someone else for
instance um you know we're we're suing
the board of pharmacy right now for for
cannabis descheduling because it's still
on the books but if you were to send
your buddy 15 bucks because you went to
a dispensary and you got half of you
know half of a pack of edibles back
you might be subject to
a felony at that point but even if you
weren't even if it was lower under this
provision a court could still consider
whether whether or not to decide to keep
you out of specific areas of town what
kind of uh
concerns have you brought to maybe city
council members or the mayor's office
about something like this there's huge
issues there i mean first and foremost
you know one of the provisions of the
bill that they have is that a court uh
is to consider factors and they're to
ask the person um that is before them
the defendant that's before them
specific factors about whether or not it
might interfere with employment or their
housing or or religious services but
that's such a big area what happens six
months from now you don't know you're
going to pass through the area you're
driving and you're just going through
the area now you're violating the order
out provision which means that they can
come back at that point and charge you
with another misdemeanor for violating
that so
these issues are you know to be raised
this is a pattern you know from our
perspective of behavior that's been
engaged in by government we're
continuing to broaden the powers of
government the policing powers and
regulatory powers of government it's not
making people any safer they're not
drawing any analogies to what's actually
occurring
because if they were then the data would
back it up but data's been scarce
city of las vegas staff say this
proposal is going to go to a
recommending committee and then go back
to the full council for action it is on
the agenda for this upcoming week las
vegas mayor carolyn goodman declined our
request for an interview or interview on
this topic
clark county school district has plans
in the works to try and address the
ongoing teacher shortage it is a
nationwide problem though on wednesday
first lady jill biden hosted a white
house meeting with education officials
governors and executives on the matter
anna warneke reports
good evening the biden administration
says their new plan will help fill
vacancies at schools across the nation
by making it easier for applicants to
find and apply for job openings as
students head back to class this fall
schools across the country are
struggling to staff their classrooms our
districts are having a harder time not
just finding eligible candidates but
really any candidates at all tennessee
commissioner of education penny schwinn
says the biden administration's new plan
will fix that on wednesday first lady dr
jill biden an administration officials
met with state and local leaders and top
executives of job search companies like
zip recruiter and handshake to announce
a new partnership that will help schools
fill their vacancies if we're serious in
addressing the teacher shortage issue we
must first address the teacher respect
issue
and the white house says the pandemic
has made the staffing challenges worse
the biden administration is encouraging
state and school district leaders to use
the money in the american rescue plan to
increase teachers salaries
if we want educators to be able to do
what they do best we have to give them
the pay and the support that they need
new jersey governor phil murphy agrees
we need to pay educators more money
there's no question about that
the white house is also reaching out to
college students to help recruit and
prepare them for a career in education
they're planning to host a virtual
nationwide event this october for now in
washington i'm anna wernicke back to you
ccsd's plan includes nationwide license
reciprocity paid application fees and
higher wages
what's next for student loans coming up
on politics now we explore potential
long-term fixes to the rising cost of
higher ed
news now
you're watching politics now
the biden administration's plan to
cancel 10 thousand dollars in student
loans has certainly met with some
opposition to break down the court
challenges and any long-term potential
fixes i spoke with cbs news's natalie
brandt
well natalie cutting student loan debt
was certainly a big goal for democrats
before we discuss some of the pushback
in washington let's just talk about how
the president's plan
would help potentially college graduates
hi john good to be joining you yeah this
is a three-part plan that was announced
the the first piece of it is extending
the pause for a final time extending
that pause on payments for the final
time through december 31st of 2022 so
the end of this year and then people
will need to begin repaying their loans
but the big headline that got a lot of
attention was that up to twenty thousand
dollar debt cancellation for pell grant
recipients and then up to ten thousand
dollars if an individual makes less than
125
000
dollars now another big part of this
plan that a lot of advocacy groups have
been highlighting
is president biden proposed a rule to
create a new income driven repayment
plan which would allow borrowers to pay
no more than five percent of their
monthly discretionary income on
undergraduate loans and that would be
cut in half down from 10
currently so that's a big piece of this
that advocacy groups believe will make a
big difference once this is implemented
now
as you probably know people are still
kind of waiting to sign up for this
we are told that in coming weeks people
can do so
uh with the hope that people can be able
to apply
uh later this fall in order for things
to kick in next year so that's what
president biden wants that's what
advocates are saying but there's
certainly some pushback and it's beyond
just lawmakers in washington there are
some other court challenges possible
from the corporate world as well what is
the pushback right now to this proposal
yeah well as you mentioned quite a bit
of pushback from republicans here in
washington in terms of the potential
cost of this plan
impact on the economy and in terms of
legal challenges
there are reports that state
republican attorneys general may be
pursuing or kind of assessing some of
their options here as well as
conservative groups so we'll have to see
whether those legal challenges do
materialize now president biden was
actually asked by reporters about this
and he said you know people have a right
to take this to court but the
administration actually put out its own
uh legal justification for this by the
department of justice saying that
there is a law on the books passed by
congress back in 2003
which allows the executive branch and
the department of education to make to
make these sort of changes to the
federal borrowing system during times of
national emergency
referencing the covid19 pandemic in this
latest legal memo so the administration
here is saying that this is still
because of the continued financial
impact of the pit of the pandemic and
that's some of their legal basis to
justify these major changes i'm also
curious and maybe i'm not sure if you
can address this but if the legal
challenge to the president's executive
order for this this college proposal the
college student loan debt forgiveness is
roughly the same as the executive orders
from former president trump when he was
trying to build the wall down on the
southern border well i mean what we saw
and what we've seen with a number of
executive orders uh just in in history
is that they get tied up in court and
then that raises the question of is
implementation delayed uh while this
plays out in courtrooms uh does this go
head up to the
u.s supreme court will have to wait and
see
senator jackie rosen from here in nevada
is involved in two proposed laws on
higher ed costs for doctors right now
sort of tied into this one pauses
repayments for medical residents and
interns the other helps rural physicians
with loan debt
some legal experts think recent supreme
court rulings could resurrect yucca
mountain the proposed nuclear waste dump
site about 90 miles north of las vegas
it's been put on a shelf by the last
several presidential administrations but
a law passed by congress still specifies
the permanent storage site for the waste
has to be at yucca mountain recent
supreme court rulings have rolled back
administrative rulings insisting states
must follow what congress says yucca
mountain could once again become an
issue here in nevada despite almost
bipartisan opposition
next on 8 news now more restrictions on
the way the next step in several water
restrictions that could kick in by the
end of the year
hello and i approve this message
[Music]
a look at washington dc one of many
places we'll be watching next week as
things progress on capitol hill
in addition to washington d.c we'll be
watching what's happening here in
southern nevada and on what to watch
more water restrictions potentially on
the horizon the las vegas valley water
district is considering the business
impacts of three new proposals
higher prices for the biggest water
users limiting some water features and
less water for golf courses that meeting
is on thursday a final vote is expected
sometime in october
then on thursday or also on thursday i
should say the clark county school
district board plans to update its
student discipline plan and we're
waiting to see how they try and balance
suspending fewer students
and also cutting down on violence in the
classrooms an issue we saw quite a bit
in the last school year we'll continue
to follow that at ccsd moving forward
that'll do it for us here on politics
now stay up to date online with all
things political nationwide and here in
nevada at eight newsnow dot com we're
back with you here on saturday we thank
you so much for watching take care
[Music]